in this video i explain the bbi
nominal test to you in a simple way after
this video you will know what the domain
test is when you use it and how
you can calculate it if you want to read the
topics from this video again
just take a look at
our book  you can find the link in the
video description and let's start
now what is a phenomenon is the
quick answer is the bbi nominal
test is a hypothesis test so a
test like this is only used if you
go out but want to say something about the population as a random sample
so the bbi nominal test is
one of many hypothesis tests the
big question is when do you use
a minimal test you use
maja the bee is if you want to check whether
the frequency distribution of a
dichotomous variable corresponds to a suspected
or expected
distribution but slowly what is one
frequency distribution what is a
digital variable and what is it
assumed frequency we start with the
dichotomy variable one the atom
variable is a categorical variable
with two characteristics
an example of this would be gender
with the two characteristics male and
female
the variable buys a product with the
characteristics yes or no or
married with the characteristics yes and
no, that brings us to the frequency
distribution the frequency distribution
indicates how a certain value
occurred, for example,
a survey could come out that 19
people are male around 24 people
actually or twelve people have
bought a product and 24 people have
no pressure  bought or 30 people
have stated that they are married
and 29 that they are not married
so that the frequency is now given as the distribution
of a variable and the
last term is the presumed or
expected distribution with the b nominal
test you want to check whether the
frequency distribution of your  maybe  riable corresponds to
a presumed or expected
frequent distribution so of course you have to
specify an expected frequency distribution with the ruler test
you can then compare both frequencies
for example the
presumed frequency distribution could be
that 21 people are male and 22
person are female or that new people are
buying  and 27 people do not buy or
that 33 people are married and 17 are
not but this assumed
or expected
frequency comes from your
population  to
examine whether the proportion of women and
men in
management positions corresponds to that of the total population
or in the second example you could
test whether a new sales page in
your online shop delivers better sales figures
than the old page die
presumed frequencies while then the
sale is the old page
let's take a look at an example the
numbers for this example are
intended to be free domicile you want to find out whether
there are as many iphone users among students at a
university as there are in
the rest of the german population
here in germany, apple has a
market share of 30 percent in the
mobile phone market,
so what you asked participants in a small survey at the university
,
are you currently using an iphone with the
answer options yes and no, if
that isn’t even a
really well-designed survey, then i don’t know the
results either  After the survey, you
then enter a table where each row is a
person asked, so the first
person asked answered yes, the second person answered
no, and so on and so on.
From this table, you can then
create a table that is often used as a table
statistics software offers from the
frequency hervelle k  then you can
see how many
people answered yes in a survey, in
this case seven, and how many people
answered no, in this
case 12. your initial question was that the
percentage of iphone users at your
university deviates statistically significantly from
that of the entire german population
in all of germany the
iphone has a share of 30 percent
so our expected share of
iphone users is 30 percent to now
check whether the observed
results deviate statistically significantly from the expected results
you use a ruler test what are
the hypotheses but
no me age is 0 hypothesis would be in
our case there is no difference
between the frequency distribution of
iphone users at a university and in the
german population
and the alternative hypothesis is there is
a difference between the
frequency distribution of iphone users
at his university and in  the German
population  lkerung
so only hypotheses there is no
difference and in the alternative
hypothesis there is a difference that
would be non-directional or 2-sided
hypotheses of course you can also
formulate directional or one-sided prostheses
in this case the alternative
hypothesis would be either the iphone part in
your university  is below 30 percent or
the iphone share and one is more than 30
percent
in the case of bino majority is one of
the statements as a success 6 s and one of the
expression as a failure
these terms are used as arbitrary
designations for the two alternative
results when we are about
speaking a disease the meaning is
obvious when it comes to whether
a person has an iphone or
not this designation is lucky on
you either you call using
the iphone a success or
not using it a success because the
probability of use is
given we define the  use
spirit success
otherwise we would have to use 70 percent for
non-use then that would be
our success i hope there wo
n't be too many discussions in the
comments about whether the use
of an iphone can be seen as a success
or not so now there are two more
sections for  those of you who are
impatient and actually just
want to know how to calculate a flower test
online with data pack
I will show them shortly afterwards
we will also go through
what actually happens with the beer nominal test
when you calculate a normal
test with netapp  just want to google
for datatec copy your data the
table and click on this tag now
you can simply select a variant
that you want to evaluate
if your variable only has two
characteristics calculated that the
automatically own images majority fixed
now only had to enter the expected
frequency  in our case get 30
percent
afterwards  t given only the results from the
test house our new hypothesis
is the
probability of success is 30 percent
the proven ones now give you the following for
the first case how likely is
it that we will get a result that has
three or fewer successes when the
probability of success
is 30 percent in  third case how likely
is it that we will get an outcome
that has three or more successes if the
probability of success is actually 30 percent and the undirected case
would be how likely is it that we will
get a result that is one
point off the expected outcome
because so less  who have three
successes or five years more
successes don't worry we'll go into all three
cases in a graphic way if we have set the significance level at five percent
, all three proven are greater than 0 5
and we can therefore not use the 0
hypothesis  discard with that we assume
that the  sample comes from a
population in which the probability of occurrence is 30 percent
, so it is assumed that
in your June there is the same frequency
distribution as in the rest of the
population now, but slowly,
now let's take a
closer look at it so that the calculation goes a
little further  passes i have modified the example from
just a little so we have
in the german population the
proportion is 14 percent the result of your
random sample is that three out of ten
people use an iphone in the first
step we now calculate
the probability of occurrence of each
possible target
So we calculate how
likely it is that we
draw a sample in which 0 out of ten
people own an iphone if the
probability of success is 40 percent
this probability is
0006 further we calculate how
likely it is to draw a sample
in which one out of ten people  an
ipho  ne has if the
probability of success is 40 percent
this probability is 0.04
and we will do that for all further
cases on your appearance our
expected value is has four appearance of
course also the highest
probability of occurrence the further
you get to the edges the
less likely it will be  respective
result now i get how
probable each individual event
is let's start with the directed
hypothesis that of the ten people who
vertigo asked three had an
iphone now the question is how
probable is it if the
probability of success is 40 percent
that we have three or less one  to
do this we simply sum
the probabilities that
we have 0 hits one hit two hits
and three hits plus 10 if the
probability of success is 40 percent
hence the probability that we have
three or fewer hits at a
60 percent probability of success
have is
0.006 plus
0.04 plus
0.1 21 plus
0.2 15 which equals 0 3 822 this
value is greater than the significance
level of 0.04 and we thus reject the
new hypothesis that the
probability of success leading you is the percent  not from it is just 38 2
percent likely that this data
comes from a population in which
the population probability is 40
percent yoy and that is quite
likely, which is why we retained the zero
hypothesis if we had
drawn it against a sample in which we
only had one  If we had
had success then the calculation would be as
follows then we would
ask how likely it is that
we have one or less success
drawing with a
probability of success of 40 percent
the result would be
0.006 +0 04 which is equal to 00 46 and
00 46 is therefore less than  0.05 and we
would therefore no longer retain 0
thesis it is only 4.6 percent
likely that this is the case  data come from
a population in which the
probability of success is 40 percent that's
why the prosthesis has been seen
we see it as unlikely
enough that this result has come about
if the
probability of success is suddenly percent
now we can also
look at the other targeted hypothesis as to how
likely it is  It's that we have three or
more hits out of ten when we have
a 40
percent chance of success for your we now
all probability right from 3 to
once the three is considered so
the probability that we have three
or more hits off when
the chance of success is 40  percent
is equal to 0.83 wear this value
is of course greater than zero
and thus the 0 the prosthesis that
the probability of success is 40 percent
is retained
the probability that we will
draw a sample that has three or more
successes in a success
vote  probability of 40 percent
has is 83 percent fit of course is very
likely this brings us to
the last hypothesis the undirected
hypothesis with a
probability of success of 40
percent the expected value is four successes
our sample has three successes because
I’m one point out of four from the
expected value we  want to know how
likely it is that we will get a
result that has equal
or more of four successes knows how
the result of our random sample that was
complicated now so again slowly
with a
probability of success and it is percentage is the expected value
in 10 cases four successes we  had
three successes in our sample so we
need one out of four since we
want to calculate an undirected hypothesis
we therefore go from four to the
left and one to the right if we had had
one success in our sample
the difference to 43 would have been and we
would have three to the left  U.N  d three to the
right we go with the case to calculate
how likely it is that we
deviate one or more from four so
we add up the probability of
3 and less and of 5 and more
the result is 07 49
9 i.e. the probability that we have
a sample  pull the three or
less or five or more is
0.7492 in this case we could have simply
calculated 10 251 so I hope
you liked the video as I said
you can also find the content in our the
link is in the video  description
sweet and see you next time